total le groupe total au procès de la
catastrophe
j'ai aujourd'hui de la raffinerie total
de la mède comparaissent pour homicides
et blessures involontaires
[Musique]
en décembre 1999 le naufrage du
pétrolier erika avait provoqué une
catastrophe écologique sur les côtes de
bretagne de vendée
[Musique]
après treize ans de bataille judiciaire
la sphère de l'erika est terminée la
cour de cassation la plus haute
juridiction française a confirmé que le
groupe total était bien responsable tant
sur le plan civil que pénal de la
catastrophe
c'est 13 ans de bataille de la part des
collectivités locales que j'ai eu
l'honneur de défendre mais c'est aussi
je pense un très grand jour pour tous
les défenseurs de l'environnement d'où
l'émotion que la mienne aujourd'hui
10h21 à trois kilomètres du centre ville
de toulouse
de très fortes explosions séparées de
quelques secondes proviennent de l'usiné
chimique azf
l'ancien directeur de l'usiné a été
condamné à 15 mois de prison avec sursis
et dix mille euros damende la société
grande paroisse filiale de total à 225
mille euros l'amendé maximale la rupture
d'une canalisation dans la raffinerie
total de donges a provoqué une fuite de
400 tonnes de pétrole
[Musique]
on est néanmoins condamné sur le plan du
délit de pollution là aussi on emprunte
la pollution des eaux et reconnu par la
justice
elle se solde par une amende de 300
mille euros répartis entre 21 des 24
parties civiles une indemnisation au
titre du préjudice moral
[Musique]
à